this video is sponsored by the american
lung cancer screening initiative
lung cancer is the leading cause of
cancer-related death in the world
but lung cancer screening can save lives
click the link below to learn more
lung cancer prevention includes actions
you can take to lower your chance of
developing cancer
the most important thing you can do to
prevent lung cancer
is to not start smoking or to quit
smoking if you do
avoid breathing in other people's smoke
test your home for radon a known
carcinogen
or cancer-causing agent
avoid exposure to cancer-causing
chemicals at work
maintain a healthy weight because being
overweight can cause the body to
circulate
higher levels of certain hormones that
can stimulate cancer growth
eat a diet full of fruits and vegetables
which are packed with substances
that can help reduce your risk of cancer
and help control your weight
exercise regularly which will help you
control your weight
and reduce your risk through its
positive influence on your hormone
levels
and immune system be sure and talk to
your doctor
about ways to reduce your risk of lung
cancer